on y revient également tout à l'heure et
n'hésitez pas à commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag qu à g et on va tout de
suite rejoindre réalise bardot dans
l'hémicycle du sénat car dans une heure
maintenant vont commencer les questions
d'actu et il va notamment être question
du mali après la mort lundi de 13
militaires engagés dans l'opération
marque anna lee sang hee witam l'un des
sujets du jour c'est bien sûr la
situation au mali vous l'avais dit au
lendemain de l'annoncé de la mort de
treize militaires français dont le fils
du sénateur jean marie bockel l'émotion
devrait toujours être vivent ici au
sénat après l'hommage d'hier dans
l'hémicycle mais un débat s'est ouvert
celui de la présence de troupes
françaises au sahel il y aura deux
questions à ce sujet tout à l'heure l'un
des autres sujets du jour c'est la
réforme des retraites et un climat
social de plus en plus tendu à la proche
de la date fatidique du 5 décembre jour
de grève nationale mais le premier
ministre a réaffirmé à l'instant sa
détermination pour mener à bien cette
réforme et cela devrait se ressentir
tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle voilà
pour le programme je vous retrouve donc
tout à l'heure juste avant l'ouverture
de la séance des questions d'actualité
merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes ces
explications alors en 24 heures on est
passé de l'émotion et de l'hommage au
débat qui s'ouvre sur la présence
française sur place tout de suite les
explications de béatrice faisant ils ont
marqué une minute de silence en hommage
aux treize militaires français morts au
mali hier dans la collision accidentelle
de deux hélicoptères un drame national
qui touche tout particulièrement les
sénateurs je suis certain qu'au moment
nous allons partager ce moment de
recueillement
vous aurez une pensée pour ses treize
militaires pour leur famille et plus
particulièrement pour une famille chère
à notre coeur que nous croisons
au quotidien dans notre assemblée tu
crois que c'est aussi un hommage que
nous devons rendre à ses hommes à leur
courage est au service de la france
en effet parmi les victimes figurent
pierre bockel fils de l'ancien ministre
et sénateur du haut rhin
il était lieutenant et avait 28 ans
notre peine est immense
notre fils était un des deux pilotes
celui du coup leur une chine que le sait
bien c'est la quatrième fois qu'il
venait en opex au mali et s'il accepte
de vous parler c'est aussi un peu pour
les peaux lui rendre hommage car je n'ai
évidemment pas le lequel rosselat hier
soir une cérémonie était organisée en
mémoire de l'ensemble du 5e régiment
d'hélicoptères de pau avant l'hommage
national qui aura lieu lundi aux
invalides et tout de suite on va
rejoindre quel match quand un calme est
qu'il se trouve dans la salle des
conférences à votre micro andré
reichardt sénateurs et l'air il est
également président du groupe france
afrique de l'ouest homme bon jour andré
reichardt est effectivement on voit
cette émotion depuis hier très forte
également les interrogations qui se
posent notamment sur la présence de la
france dans cette zone d'afrique
est-ce que selon vous est la partie de
la france à ce conflit elle est
indispensable elle est indispensable
bien sûr puisqu'elle a été demandée par
les pays concernés rappelons-nous bien
sûr notre intervention s'est faite à la
demande de république du mali alors la
question bien sûr est de savoir ce qu'on
y fait encore est-ce que
goût de maintenant quelques années notre
présence est indispensable
gérez votre opinion et je pense que oui
bien entendu il suffit de voir que au
mali cela continue même si dans l'or ça
se calme un petit peu on voit que
maintenant c'est le centre du mali s'est
naturellement l'est toujours mais ce qui
est beaucoup plus grave c'est que c'est
que la gangrène est à l'oeuvre et j'ai
eu l'occasion de poser une question
d'actualité concernant le burkina faso
il ya peu une quinze jours maintenant il
faut éviter que ce soit le tour du
burkina faso alors on entend aussi à
l'appel de christian cambon le président
au sénat de la commission de la défense
qui réclament l'aide d'autres pays
européens surtout des aides un des
moyens en hommes
est ce que ça peut être quelque chose
qui peut se passer dans les prochaines
semaines ça c'est à espérer c'est c'est
un constat que nous dressons la france
est bien seul dans dans ce conflit mais
je vais sentiment qu'un certain nombre
de pays voire de nombreux pays d'europe
ne se rendent pas compte que que ce que
l'on fait à l'heure actuelle dans le
sahel c'est ni plus ni moins qu assurer
notre propre liberté
c'est notre propre sécurité à nous l'a
simplement en france qui est en jeu et
donc faire comprendre ça à d'autres pays
d'europe c'est indispensable moi je
milite pour ça ma question d'actualité à
l'époque
enfin iliad époque à quinze jours ne
portait que sur cela pas des moyens
supplémentaires de barkan franchement on
n'en a pas beaucoup plus à m ont fait
déjà quatre mille hommes là-bas bien et
on en est appelé toutes parts je citais
le burkina faso si on pouvait être au
burkina faso un peu plus présent ils
seraient ils seraient ravis
bien sûr on va ce quasi consensus
politique en france sur le fait qu'il
faut continuer l'opération barkan il ya
la france soumise qui elle de son côté
appelle un débat et pour jean luc
mélenchon il ya une perte de sens
dans cet organe dans cette opération
qu'est-ce que vous ne répondez aux
leaders de la france soumise m'écoutais
je ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'il entend
par perdre deux sens moi j'ai eu
l'occasion d'aller dans ces pays à l'une
ou l'autre occasion tout
particulièrement au mali à gao près de
l'endroit de ce drame
moi j'ai vu qu'il y avait du sens moi
j'ai vu qu'il y avait une armée
française qui qui étaient là pour pour
faire du bon travail et qui le fait et
je n'ose pas penser à l'état dans
laquelle seraient l'afrique de l'ouest à
l'heure actuelle si la france n'avait
pas été et je répète c'est absolument
anormal que nous y soyons seul merci
beaucoup andré reichardt et on verra
dans l'hémicycle induira des questions
qui seront consacrés à la situation au
mali effectivement nous allons avoir
l'occasion de revenir sur cette question
du mali tout au long de cette émission
mais pour l'heure on va passer aux
premiers débats de cette émission alors
que le sénat est en plein débat
budgétaire
on va s'intéresser à cette question le
verger 2020 est il vraiment vers le
gouvernement fait valoir des efforts à
la hauteur de l'urgence climatique érigé
en priorité mais les associations jugent
que le compte n'y est pas pas facile d'y
voir clair dans la bataille des chiffres
mais on va essayer avec la baraque terre
difficile de savoir combien le
gouvernement entend vraiment consacré à
l'écologie
l'exécutif vente les 32,2 milliards
d'euros affecté au ministère de la
transition écologique soit une
augmentation de plus de 800 millions
d'euros pour 2020 moi je vois plutôt une
ambition une ambition une volonté qui
est celle aujourd'hui du gouvernement
que de mener à bien cette nécessaire
transition écologique mais surtout de
mener ce qu'on appelle la transition
écologique et solidaire parce que il n'y
aura de transition que si effectivement
le mot solidaire est affirmé et
réaffirmé et on le voit dans le cadre
des mesures qui seront proposées pour ce
projet de loi de finances 2009 1
l'opposition dénonce un affichage cette
somme incluant certaines dépenses sans
rapport avec l'écologie
et quand bercy additionne ministère par
ministère tous les crédits affectés à la
transition écologique
le résultat paraît moins ambitieux 16,4
milliards d'euros seulement
des sommes qui restent en tout cas loin
des objectifs annoncés dans une feuille
de route du gouvernement l'an dernier
qui chiffrait les besoins en matière de
transition énergétique entre 45 et 85
milliards d'euros par an
il faut la volonté politique ensuite les
chiffres en face et comment avec les
moyens que l'on là parce qu'ils ne sont
pas exponentielle
comment on fait nos politiques et là on
est véritablement dans la question du
choix politique d'autant que les
recettes fiscales sont bien là en 2018
l'ensemble de la fiscalité écologique
avait rapporté plus de 50 milliards
d'euros à l'état d'après la cour des
comptes alors ce budget il à la hauteur
de l'urgence climatique on va en
débattre avec quatre invités sur ce
plateau du plaisir d'accueillir jean
françois husson
bonjour vous êtes sénateur l ère de la
meurthe et moselle vice président de la
commission des finances également avec
nous rendent en tête
bonjour sénateurs au groupe ps de la
loire atlantique vice président de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
match équipe bienvenus vous êtes
secrétaire général de l'union des
démocrates et des écologistes
vous êtes assez proche de la majorité
actuelle sur les questions
environnementales et enfin anne
bringault vous êtes responsable
transition énergétique du réseau action
climat tout d'abord première question
pour vour dantec est ce vraiment un
budget vert tout simplement non non
c'est pas un budget qui va permettre
d'atteindre les objectifs même tout le
monde le sait je crois je crois surtout
dans le dernier chiffre inquiet citée
dans le reportage que la fiscalité
écologique aujourd'hui c'est plus de 50
milliards 56 58 milliards ça c'est les
recettes pour l'état les dépenses liées
à l'environnement en ne reprenant même
que le budget du ministère de
l'environnement de la transition
écologique et solidaire
c'est dans les 30 milliards donc je
crois que tu arrêtes à 30 milliards on a
fait un calcul formé de l'autre mais moi
je crois que les français ont compris et
ça a été tout le débat sur la
contribution carbone et ça a été un
débat douloureux puisque on a bloqué
cette fiscalité qui était une fiscalité
importante
les français ont compris en finale
mangue la fiscalité écologique ne
servait pas la transition mais à un
boucler le budget de l'état et qu'à
partir de là il n'y a pas de contrat il
n'y a pas de contrat social un politique
démocratique entre les français et le
gouvernement fasse a pas commencé que
sur ce gouvernement c'est sur le fait de
faire un effort de fiscalité
environnementale mais d'avoir derrière
les
les moyens qui vont avec donc je crois
que ce budget est encore une fois un peu
sur le même base que les budgets qu'on a
pu dénoncer les années précédentes et
non non il y compris pour les
territoires mais ça avec jean face à lui
sur ma mener le combat tous les ans on
pourra le reprendre l'année prochaine on
verrait pas vous êtes vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus il n'y a pas une fiscalité qui
est à la hauteur on à nous regarder les
chiffres alors c'est vrai vous avez dit
il ya le budget du ministère il est aux
alentours de 30 milliards d'euros
elhorga aussi l'ambiance oui il est en
baisse et si on additionne tous les
crédits affectés à la transition
écologique
on est arrivé à 16,4 milliards d'euros
et le gouvernement fait valoir qu'il ya
800 millions euros de plus par rapport à
l'an dernier et lé bon il faut peut-être
les trouver au säntis l'ordre d'abord
c'est inexact tout ça c'est un peu de la
poudre de perlimpinpin pas dire qu'on a
mis quelques missions nouvelles
et puis on fait de l'habillage les
français ont compris deux choses ils ont
exprimé dans le quinquennat précédent
notamment les bretons sur l'écotaxe un
refus alors que je le dis quand même
alors que le parlement s'était prononcé
à l'unanimité
quand il ya eu l'augmentation le
raidissement de la taxe carbone j'ai
personnellement mis en garde il ya deux
ans c'était en novembre 2010 est au
premier budget présenté par le
gouvernement et donc pas gérald darmanin
en fait vous ne pouvez aujourd'hui c'est
un contrat parce qu'on a un changement
de logiciel
aujourd'hui on doit être écologique et
on doit combiner économie et je dirais
questions sociales et sociétales mais ça
va pas non mais le défi là parce qu'en
fait si vous regardez bien on a un
gouvernement qui est pas là depuis trois
ans elle j'ai eu trois ministres de
l'écologie oui je cherchais juste
l'erreur et on est passé d'un nicolas
hulot à françois de rugy à elizabeth
banks et pas forcément la même notoriété
entre le premier et la dernière mathieu
cuite votre vous votre votre avis sur ce
budget est il vraiment revers je vous ai
senti plutôt acquiescé quand on a quand
quentin lorsque j'ai demandé ça non mais
forcément quand vous augmentez un budget
de 800 millions d'euros il ya une
amélioration qui est notable mais
houle a augmenté à pabu et lé ou prudent
d'abord vous avez donc un budget à 32
milliards on peut regarder en détail
dans une bataille de chiffres chacun
amène ses chiffres ronan dantec le
disais on a faim on en est même pas
exactement sur les crêtes
le gouvernement annonce une hausse une
augmentation de 800 millions d'euros du
budget du mystère la transition
écologique
il ya de nouveaux crédits notamment
affecté l agence française de la
biodiversité
il ya 5 milliard et demi d'euros sur sur
les énergies renouvelables parce que le
gouvernement veut pousser veut pousser
là dessus vous dites non moi je vous dis
oui on est dans l'ue dont vous parliez
sur la question sociale
évidemment le budget il se doit aussi
d'être sociale et la question de
l'augmentation plus encore de ce budget
elle est liée évidemment au fait que
nous avons dû revenir sur la taxe
carbone justement parce qu'on a entendu
la grogne l'année dernière chez les
jaunes et 4 milliards ou 4 milliards et
demi qui était affecté normalement à
cette taxe carbone elle va sont pas
rentrés dans les caisses de l'état pour
faire plus encore mais au fond ce budget
est quand même une amélioration
vous vous dites non je dis oui c'est une
amélioration par rapport au budget de
l'an dernier une amélioration au budget
de l'an dernier anne bringault vous
votre avis on sait que beaucoup
d'associations sont plutôt déçus parce
qu'il y avait les annonces un budget à
la hauteur et puis la réalité vous c'est
clairement pas un budget vert on n'a pas
assez d'argent pour rénover les
logements notamment pour les plus
précaires on n'a pas assez d'argent pour
accompagner tous les ménages pour les
aider techniquement et financièrement à
rénover leur logement
on n'a pas assez d'argent pour les
accompagner vers des changements de
véhicules ou vers d autres mobilité les
transports en commun je parlerai pas des
lignes de train les les pistes cyclables
tout ça ça manque cruellement et on a au
contraire donné plutôt ouvert la brèche
à des financements privés avec les
certificats d'économie d'énergie qui
sortent du coup de du budget public
pierre on a en fait c'est plus de 16
milliards qui vont à des activités
néfastes pour le climat c'est à dire
qu'on donne au moins autant pour ce qui
est contraire au climat que ce qui est
pour le climat par exemple des niches
fisc
sur le transport aérien par exemple des
niches fiscales sur le transport de fret
transport routier de marchandises
tout cet argent là va alimenter les
énergies fossiles et finalement renforce
le système qui fait qu'on va continuer à
utiliser des màj fossiles pire la france
finance les projets d'énergies fossiles
à l'étranger non seulement en france on
n'est pas exempt plat mais en plus on va
garantir à l'export des projets
d'exploitation ou de centrales qui
utilisent les énergies fossiles
donc on n'est pas du tout sur un budget
vert bien au contraire nous vous jugez
que le gouvernement ment lorsqu'il dit
que c'est un budget à la hauteur de
l'urgence il fait clairement du
greenwashing
il en est parfaitement conscient alors
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
question des gilets jaunes c'est
important de cibler les bonnes priorités
d'y mettre suffisamment d'argent et de
faire accepter cela aux français le
sujet c'est de ne pas crispés les
français face à une fiscalité verte qui
a été vécu bien comme punitive par
beaucoup et qui a été l'étincelle donc
pour déclencher le mouvement des gilet
jaune cet épisode a été rappelé cette
semaine par albéric de montgolfier le
rapporteur général du budget on écoute
et on en parle juste après senna est
particulièrement jeudi devant jean
françois buisson qui s'est exprimé en
premier par tirman légitime pour traiter
cette question parce que il a été le
premier à alerter sur l'augmentation
pluriannuel de l'énergie à travers ce
qui s'était passé notamment sur la
fiscalité de la tpe et sa non pas de la
dernière
mais dès le plf d'il ya deux ans où jean
françois buisson avait dit attention les
augmentations qui ne seraient pas
compensés par ailleurs par un
accompagnement des français auraient des
conséquences risquerait de provoquer des
mouvements vous le savez à l'époque il
avait dit de bonnets rouges et
finalement nous avons eu un gilet jaune
jean-françois ils sont vous êtes un peu
la madame irma du sénat
ronan dantec vous aussi certes albert de
mon coach n'a pas parlé de vous mais
vous avez exactement donné l' alerte au
même moment et vous aviez donc voilà on
prend un contre
nous n'avons que des madame irma alors
jean françois husson vous aviez vu
arriver le mouvement des gilet jaune de
loin pour vous quel a été à ce moment là
l'erreur du gouvernement
mais l'erreur ne pas reproduire l'erreur
du gouvernement c'est que vous allez
voir je crains qu il se passe la même
chose sur les retraites il faut
aujourd'hui on est devant un changement
de modèle de société de consommation et
il faut le faire progressivement et il
faut associer nos concitoyens parce que
moi je pense que l'économie doit passer
sur un modèle plus décarbonée on voit
également que il faut associer
l'ensemble des parties prenantes donc
les collaborateurs des entreprises
les chefs d'entreprise et puis les
collectivités or aujourd'hui on est dans
l'incantation dans l'ordre et notamment
dans la punition
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire la taxe
carbone elle était déjà avec une
trajectoire qui était on demandait de
vrais efforts le gouvernement a fait le
choix de dire oh le vote une fois et
pour cinq ans on a la majorité depuis
trois mois dont vous allez pas nous
faire la leçon voulait modeste
parlementaire en plus
très honnêtement quand on est pas du
nouveau monde et que vous venez au sénat
on a quand même l'impression de
représenter le monde d'avant-hier et je
pense au contraire qu'on est en contact
avec les français et les réalités et
donc aujourd'hui il faut absolument
partager les réflexions il faut donner
des lignes directrices et il faut le
consolider par des pactes avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
parce que même je le dis le parlement
tout seul ne suffit pas les deux
assemblées ça ne suffit pas renon dantec
il faut effectivement accompagné les
français car le problème de la fiscalité
écologique c'est que elle est
socialement injustes elles pèsent plus
sur les ménages modestes en proportion
que sur les ménages aisés m'a gardé un
graphique de l'inspection générale des
finances sur ce graphique on voit
qu'elle représente 80 que le 6 % du
revenu pour un ménage modeste et là on
voit que le revenu de plus en plus
élevés et 1,1 pour cent pour les plus
riches
c'est donc essentiel de soutenir et
d'accompagner à bas il y avait un
symbole alors le gouvernement un petit
peu bougé sur ce point puisqu'il a
repris est le mécanisme que nous nous
avions proposé
au sénat sur la taxation de l'aérien
mais quand on disait aux français qu'ils
modeste qui partait en voiture à nice
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de se
payer l'avion qui paye la taxe carbone
et que ceux qui a les moyens de se payer
quatre billets d'avion ne la paient pas
ce niveau d'injustice sociale évidemment
au bout d'un moment ça finit par nous
péter à la figure
mais je crois que le problème principal
qu'on a et qui à mon ami n'est pas réglé
et là c'est de la responsabilité du
président de la république et du premier
ministre de donner des consignes très
claires c'est que pour bercy l'enjeu
c'est pas la transition énergétique et
climatique et rend donc le budget oui et
que effectivement à partir du moment où
la taxe carbone a été vue comme une
vache à lait qu'on n'a pas une histoire
derrière y compris de la redistribution
on avait proposé une double resterez de
redistribution m'avait proposé de rendre
extrêmement vers les territoires c'est
quelque chose que j'avais lancé avec le
maire de dunkerque est l'adjointe de
bordeaux au moment des assises de
l'énergie c'était il ya 4 5 ans dire si
vous n'aimez pas les territoires on est
de rendre obligatoires les les plans
climat
ça ne va pas passer là le gouvernement a
dit non et 100 francs solution qui étais
tu lui aussi a remis avec christine
lagarde
l'amendement compass tous les ans
l'unamité on va voir ce qui va se passer
à l'assemblée
mais là ils ne nous ont pas entendus ils
ne nous ont pas entendus sur la
redistribution un chèque énergie un
chèque transport et derrière ils ont
perdu beaucoup d'argent parce que cette
fiscalité là et quand même une fiscalité
intéressante pour modifier les
comportements à partir des effectivement
au moment où on répond aux injustices
sociales qu'elle peut créer
mais là on a un gouvernement et bercy je
pense aujourd'hui sincèrement on en fait
encore bouger son logiciel sa priorité
c'est par la transition qu'il mâtine
mathieu crypte est ce que bercy a bougé
son logiciel ou est ce qu'ils continuent
à utiliser et bien tout ce budget pour
justement le boucler toutes séries tout
ça pour simplement pour boucler le
budget rssi et l'administration fiscale
peut porter une politique ce n'est pas
celle que porte le premier nice où le
président de la république un bon moment
minimes cadets c'est le président de la
république qui impulsent une politique a
fortiori s'impliquent aujourd'hui
beaucoup sur les questions écologiques
c'est mieux qu'en début de quinquennat
c'est sûr sur la question des gilets
jaunes évidemment qu'il y avait une
urgence sociale et que cette question de
fiscalité écologique elle est venue au
fond comme une étincelle sur un
ras-le-bol fiscal qui était global qui
datent pas évidemment du début du
quinquennat mais qui avait déjà commencé
bien avant sous le quinquennat
chirac sarkozy hollande etc etc en
particulier sur les territoires ruraux
moi même je suis impliqué dans la région
sont de val de loire dans un département
très rural
je vois bien où on a vu là le départ de
l'état tout ça ce sont des questions qui
sont très liées parce qu'il ya plus
transports publics à plus de train et
c'est là où je rejoins ronan dantec et
j'ai un désaccord avec le gouvernement
là tu sais effectivement donné aux
territoires plus de pouvoir plus de
moyens accompagner les territoires parce
qu'en réalité c'est souvent les
territoires et censeurs allaient prendre
acte du changement climatique est en
première ligne sur sur les solutions à
apporter
anne bringault en tout cas le
gouvernement on ne sait pas exactement
ce qu'il fait mais en tout cas ce qu'il
dit c'est qu'il communique beaucoup
regardé et un fascicule comme cette
année tiennent là pour accompagner le
projet de loi de finances 2010 a livré
de la transition écologique il fait
valoir tous azimuts que le gouvernement
favorise la biodiversité qui va vers une
agriculture biologique et durable
un plan transport une politique
énergétique ambitieuse anne bringault
qu'est ce que vous pensez
je ne mange pas les slogans de ce beau
dépliants par contre sur la fiscalité
c'est important d'avoir en tête que les
français ce qu'ils veulent c'est une
transition est une transition qui soit
juste et une fiscalité juste il centre à
faire des efforts mais il faut que ces
efforts soient équitablement répartis
s'était pas le cas vous l'avez montré
c'est le plus modestes et ceux qui
vivent en milieu rural qui est des
analyses en cinq ans donc il faut que
l'art jeunes qu'ils soient collectées
aille vers la transition vers des
nouveaux véhicules va des mobilités
différentes va la rénovation des
logements pour baisser la facture
d'énergie des ménages
et il faut aussi que cette fiscalité
touche d'autres secteurs l'aviation qui
ne payent pas il faut faire une taxe
c'est très insuffisant
c'est le remplacement des radars du tout
ça suffira il faut augmenter le prix de
l'avion et baisser le prix du train
c'est pas logique actuellement ça soit
quatre fois moins cher de prendre
l'avion alors que prendre le train est
beaucoup plus écologique il faut
également pour les ménages qui n'ont pas
que ça un choix qui nous sont obligés de
prendre la voiture pour aller travailler
et bien qu'ils aient une redistribution
une sorte de chèque énergie pour
attendre le moment où il y aura des
véhicules moins polluants véhicules
électriques ou biogaz qui seront
accessibles en occasions par exemple
pour ces ménages
donc il ya vraiment des solutions par
contre c'est une solution globale et qui
soit juste qu'il faut travailler pendant
trois mois j'ai vu le veut le slogan la
biodiversité une priorité les le nombre
de salariés des parcs nationaux vont
encore baisser cette année remonte tous
les territoires
la souffrance des agents dans les parcs
nationaux qui n'arrivent plus à mener
leurs actions sur la protection de
l'environnement dans des lieux tout à
fait remarquable les moyens sur le
risque d dréal on l'a vu avec le
brizault ils sont en baisse aussi depuis
plusieurs années ça c'est un chiffre or
ce chiffre là dans le budget il est
clair le nombre de salariés diminue de
l'état et ça c'est essentiel parce que
les questions environnementales s'est
beaucoup d'animations il faut beaucoup
accompagnés donc on a besoin de temps
humain et saas est en train de baisser
fortement principe fonctionne pas c'est
pas anecdotique à des crises complexes
tout le discours pareil donc il faut
arrêter avec la baisse des postes et
effectivement on a quand même un budget
qui est dans la continuité d'un état
dont la priorité j'ai déjà dit c'est
simplement le déficit la réponse à
mathieu clip effectivement est-ce que ça
fait même un peu désordre d'avoir toutes
ces suppressions de postes au ministère
de l'environnement 800 suppressions de
postes dont une partie chez les
opérateurs et une partie effectivement
de région et préfet surveillance dont
météo-france absolument ses rêves dont
évidemment l'ensemble des ministères
doivent faire un effort par rapport à la
bonne gestion budgétaire et dans un
deuxième temps une partie des postes qui
sont supprimés au sein du ministère de
la transition écologique sont en réalité
réaffecté au ministère de l'intérieur
justement pour permettre une
mutualisation des secrétariats généraux
communs notamment pour pour les
territoires et vous emportez zéro
crédits sur ce que vous dites
des gens des parcs nationaux au
ministère de l'intérieur mais vous
caricaturez je vous dis que sur les 800
postes dont vous êtes que vous évoquez
il y en a 400 effectivement au ministère
qui sont qui sont aujourd'hui en
administration centrale et pas sur les
territoires et basse et caresser son
administration en disant tout ça vous
perdez une explication le slogan
français attendent et vous me dites il
ya une réduction d'effectifs vous dit
oui à une réduction d'effectifs mais sur
le chiffres qui seront annoncés vous
aviez évoqué 800 postes en jeu la roue
97 je voudrais je vous répond qu'à une
partie de ces postes là où effectivement
il ya une suppression de poste et une
autre partie où il ya une réaffectation
de ces postes un transfert au ministère
de l'intérieur pour permettre une
mutualisation entre l'intérieur et la
transition écologique notamment pour les
territoires pour conclure je
souhaiterais que nous puissions
également nous projeter un petit peu sur
l'avenir un car il ya eu un rapport du
programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement qui a été rendu public
déjà envoyé cette citation de matthieu
orphelin qui n'est que de la majorité
jean bart
il avait déclaré il a déclaré un vrai
budget vert c'est un budget qui investit
assez dans la transition écologique est
compatible avec une limitation du
réchauffement climatique à un degré et
demi on en est encore loin et regarder
justement et bien cette courbe si nous
poursuivons nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre au rythme actuel on arrive à
une augmentation de 3,4 à 3,9 degrés et
s'empare de l'ensemble du monde on
arrive à une augmentation de 3 degrés
s'ils ont su d'accord de paris et pour
arriver à contenir l'augmentation des
températures un réellement là où il le
faudrait il faudra stick mans changer
nos habitudes
regardez comme il faut il faut une
inversion de la courbe véritablement
anne bringault c'est vrai que ça fait
des années qu'on dit qu'il faut changer
qu'il y a urgence alors si on l'avait
fait il ya dix ans la courbe elle sera
un peu plus plane
maintenant on arrive vraiment au bord de
la falaise soit on se jette dans le vide
mais effectivement ça va être un petit
peu douloureux soit on attend encore
plus mais alors là on va vers la
catastrophe alors dix ans et ben ali ces
noms sont toutes hors non maintenant
l'empreinte carbone des français
c'est-à-dire les émissions liées à nos
consommations elle n'augmente pas on à
ox et exporter nos
nos émissions qui sont qui viennent des
produits qu'on importe mais finalement
ce que l'on aimait en ou en français
avec notre consommation ne baisse pas
par ailleurs on a des tendances qui sont
très négatives
la moyenne d'émission d'un véhicule neuf
en france en 2018 elle était supérieure
aux émissions d'un même véhicule neuf en
2016 le transport routier sa part
augmente alors qu'on devrait développer
on a dans nos objectifs de développer le
fret ferroviaire et le fret fluvial
donc on est vraiment sur une trajectoire
qui ne va pas dans le bon sens
il faut être très conscient du fait
qu'il va falloir sortir des énergies
fossiles donc se déplacer autrement se
chauffer au premier et réduire les
émissions de l'agriculture ça veut dire
réduire l'élevage et la consommation de
viande et réduire les engrais azotés ce
sont vraiment les axes principaux et on
ne va pas pouvoir passer à côté antec
vous qui avez travaillé sur les
conséquences qu'aurait le réchauffement
climatique
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire
concrètement à tel réchauffement des
températures
ah bah si on est à + 4 degrés nos
modèles sociétaux ne survivent pas c'est
à dire qu'on n'est pas juste a traité
des îlots de chaleur ou des sécheresses
on est sur des crises mondiales telles
que probablement un moment il ya
quelqu'un qui appuie sur le bouton
nucléaire pour provoquer un hiver
nucléaire donc
donc il faut absolument qu'on trouve une
solution on a un gouvernement qui dit
beaucoup aujourd'hui président parle
beaucoup sur ces sujets là moi je
continue de discuter avec ce
gouvernement il ya encore pour quelques
années et on n'a pas le temps d'attendre
un gouvernement qui nous serait un plus
favorable et notamment c'est quand même
sur la question je crois de l'économie
mondiale et des grands accords de libre
échange que ça va se jouer
emmanuel macron la tribune de l'onu dit
il y aura plus d'accords de
libre-échange qui ne respectent pas la
transition énergétique et climatique
j'attends donc du président et de son
gouvernement qui réponde à ça mais c'est
extrêmement douloureux parce que ça va
contre tous les intérêts économiques de
court terme mais à l'échelle mondiale il
y à des pays qui ont des résultats on a
aussi publié le rapport climate cents
sur l'action fait de l'inde et 2019 on
voit qu'il ya des pays qui ont de vrais
résultats mais qui mettent toute leur
politique en cohérence et il faut
absolument que l'économie mondiale soit
régulée par la question climatique
c'est dans le discours du gouvernement
s'est pas encore dans les années qui
éclipsent ce sont des modèles à suivre
on changeait radicalement de modèle il
faut évidemment transformé notre modèle
mais on est quand même dans une
discussion qui est globale ronan dantec
le disais quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui la chine ou l'inde où un
certain nombre de pays émergents leur
modèle s'est transformée extrêmement
rapidement en prenant le mauvais chemin
et aujourd'hui effectivement le modèle
français
pendant que cette alliance est
aujourd'hui l'inde est pas comparable à
la plus propre que les classes moyennes
européennes c'est pas qu'une question de
transfert d'informations séquence est
aussi une politique mondiale qu'il faut
qu'il faut coordonner et c'est le cas
notamment il ya une coop qui arrivent là
en espagne et c'est dans ces discussions
internationales qu'il faut aussi poussé
et pour le coup le président de la
république le fait sur la question des
accords de libre échange notamment sur
les autres on va le voir mais de plus en
plus de clause sur le géant médias sur
le ceta et merckx ou re il ya un vrai
retour en arrière puisque finalement la
majorité remarche à l'assemblée avait
voté ça en godillots
moi je crois qu'il ya un petit faut
arrêter la prise de conscience
aujourd'hui il faut agir enfin
honnêtement ça me vient à sousse qui va
pas vous dire qu'on jette
non pas du tout je nous invite
collectivement depuis le début depuis
des années à regarder avec plus de
vigilance
les modèles vers lesquels on doit
évoluer je vais vous dire c'est pas ni
en marche ni personne qui va me donner à
titre personnel et nous donner aux
français des lourds moi je crois qu'il
ya un prêt sujet le sujet c'est
aujourd'hui la france doit peser plus en
europe et il faut absolument que
l'europe et je crois qu'elle est en
train de le faire soit quelque part
notre porte étendard parce qu'il faut
peser dans la compétition mondiale
et si l'ambition de l'europe elle est
aussi de travailler sur ces enjeux
climatiques
ça nous rendra plus forts ensemble la
france sera forte si l'europe est forte
il ya aussi ce message là enfin moi je
veux tordre le cou aux populistes de
tous poils qui considère qu'il faut être
replié sur soi et en vouloir à tout le
monde ça suffit il faut être offensif il
faut se bagarrer faut le faire pour
l'écologie parce que l'écologie c'est la
vie et la vie c'est l'avenir de la
société
eh bien merci beaucoup à tous les cadres
d'avoir partie
paix à ce débat merci jean françois
husson merci ronan dantec merci anne
bringault et merci à mathieu kuip nous
allons également passé à présent aux
faits politiques du jour le débat sur
les retraites sortis du flou après avoir
reçu les partenaires sociaux pendant
deux jours le premier ministre et d'un
philippe à tout à l'heure
dis toute sa détermination il est un
petit peu précisé le calendrier des
annonces en l'écoutant je voudrais dire
que nous sommes plus que jamais si j'ose
dire
déterminé à construire ce système
universel de retraite parce que cette
réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale construire un système universel
de retraite
ça n'est pas réformer notre système
actuel c'est le refonder le refonder
pour qu'ils soient plus justes et plus
solide tout au long de ces discussions
nous avons rappelé le principe
fondamental qui sous tend ce projet de
société
remplacer les 42 régime existant par un
système unique et universel commun à
tous les français et dont les règles
seront les mêmes pour tous cette
déclaration du premier ministre est
intervenue à une semaine de la journée
de grève du 5 décembre le gouvernement
d'ailleurs se mobiliser hier le premier
ministre a remobilisé les parlementaires
de la majorité avec un mot d'ordre on ne
lâche rien marion vigreux après le
conseil des ministres de ce matin le
compte à rebours est bel et bien lancée
dans huit jours le 5 décembre c'est une
grève dure qui se profile contre la
réforme des retraites
conséquence le gouvernement se met en
ordre de bataille
ce mardi soir edouard philippe recevait
à huis clos les parlementaires de la
majorité
objectif faire le point sur l'avancée
des discussions avec les partenaires
sociaux mais surtout exhorté ses troupes
à faire bloc autour de la réforme la
majorité qui était toutefois présenté
ici sénat et assemblée est extrêmement
déterminé pour que cette réforme soit
réussie le fait qu'elle soit réussie
implique qu'on ne relâchent rien de
l'attention que nous portons aux forces
syndicales et aux français cette
détermination doit répondre à celles des
syndicats qui évoquent une montée en
puissance de la mobilisation depuis très
très longtemps ma vie
jamais eu autant de demandes notamment
de salariés dans les entreprises où il
n'y avait pas de syndicats qui voulaient
savoir comment participer le 5 décembre
par exemple dans les bouches du rhône il
ya déjà 2 145 appel à la grève dont 80
reconductible de son côté face aux
parlementaires le premier ministre
rappelle les éléments de langage et les
invite à faire de la pédagogie dans leur
circonscription
être sur le terrain auprès des citoyens
pour partager la solidarité qu'il ya au
travers de ce projet de société qui doit
permettre aux retraités les plus
modestes de voir leur pension
revalorisée c'est déjà l'essentiel de
notre engagement pour les jours qui
viennent et compris avant le 5
prochain rendez vous pour le
gouvernement un séminaire ce dimanche à
matignon pour fixer la feuille de route
et à une semaine des manifestations du 5
décembre on va parler vient de la
réforme des retraites avec rené pas que
ça n'arrive bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de la main vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales et rapporteur retraite pour
cette même commission également sur ce
plateau et chariots ou bonjour sénateurs
la république en marche représentant les
français établis hors de france vous
étiez d'ailleurs hier à cette réunion
avec les parlementaires de la majorité
alors que vous a dit le premier ministre
est-ce qu'il a re mobiliser les troupes
est ce que les troupes alliées en avait
besoin
oui je pense qu'il a eu la main discours
très très offensif
une grande partie de ce qu'il a dit
était au fond un compte rendu des
entretiens qu'ils avaient eu le lundi et
le mardi avec l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales
je vais pas rentrer dans les détails
mais enfin nous a fait un tableau au
fond assez nuancé sur les résultats de
ces de ses contacts avec bien sûr
certains certaines forces syndicales qui
sont tout à fait opposés
au projet à l'universalité etc mais
d'autres qui sont qui amènent des
propositions qui sont prêts à discuter
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs le premier
ministre a dit qu'il avait eu un échange
très riche de très grande qualité avec
les partenaires sociaux il a même dit
bien les or il a cité en tous les
partenaires sociaux a dit les ententes
sur les droits familiaux l'emploi des
seniors la pénibilité c'est un
gouvernement allait qu'outre n'est pas
le savoir et à écouter dans une réforme
sociétale aussi importante et vaut mieux
être à l'écouté la réforme doit faire
plus tôt avec la société avec ce qui
représente les partenaires sociaux que
contre eux j'ai aussi à l'écouté mais
apparemment il a quand même un certain
nombre de personnes qui sont contre la
réforme alors qu'on ne connaît pas
encore les tenants et les aboutissants
oui on a des préconisations à une vaste
un mode de calcul complètement différent
parce que le système pare passe quand
même pas pareil que celui que l'on
connaît sur la même trajectoire
budgétaire ce qui veut dire que si on
prend pas un certain nombre de mesures
le compte n'y est pas donc ce sont tous
ces problèmes qu'il faut encore régler
donc aujourd'hui on va voir moi je ne
suis pas madame irma maman justement sur
un mot sur la méthode quand même on a
beaucoup parlé et bien du flou de la
cacophonie au sein du gouvernement par
exemple ce qui a pu avoir sur la clause
du grand-père vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la façon dont le gouvernement
est bien à préparer cette réforme avec
avec et bien effectivement ce flou
québécois écoutez moi je trouve que
c'était bien parti j'ai été
personnellement associé au déplacement
de jean paul delvoye il a fait une
concertation large de notre côté j'ai
commencé moi faire des auditions puisque
étant désignés à l'avant ce qui montre
que le sénat est prêt à avancer dans la
dimension les retraites
et puis et puis ça traîne ça fait
maintenant presque deux ans quoi donc y
arrive à un moment il croise un surf ou
passer un moment à l'action pascal à
force de tergiverser on a l'impression
que les semaines et les mois perdus font
qu'un doute s'installe dans l'esprit des
gens elle doute ça peut être quoi ça
peut être demain on nous cache quelque
chose pour qu'on n'arrive pas parce
qu'on n'arrête pas de sortir si c'est
une réforme qui est plus juste plus
équitable
tout le monde devra prouver aux dires
des deux morts c'est pas le cas donc
faut faire attention à tout cela c'est
que l'incertitude est source souvent
d'inquiétude et oui c'était un vrai une
vraie difficulté pour le gouvernement on
a commencé à voir des annonces en tout à
l'heure richard you puisque aidant
philippe a dit qu'ils auraient bien jean
paul delevoye qui interviendrait vers le
10 décembre qu'après dans philippe va
lui-même rendre ses arbitrages
on devrait connaître le texte au début
de l'année prochaine selon m ce genre
soit sur ou pas c'est pas moi qui suis
je ne suis pas le maître des horloges
comme on dit maintenant
mais c'est effectivement dans ces eaux
là mi mi janvier les connaissez
arbitrage oui il est longtemps mais en
même temps quand on amène une réforme
qui est déjà ficelé on nous crie dessus
en disant c'est jupitérien sa tombe du
ciel c'est horrible il n'y a pas de
concertation et canton concertent
effectivement ça fait presque deux ans
que ça discute 350 réunions ont fait des
choses absolument extraordinaire alors
là on dit ah bah ça traîne c'est flou et
où il ya il reste un certain nombre de
questions centrales a tranché comme la
période de transition par exemple comme
il les rend progressive
voilà
sur les âges pivots jeu légal pas toutes
et tous et tous ces points il ya deux ou
trois grandes caisses et puis l'
équilibre financier
voilà yahia a tranché c'est le choc
restions là on n'est pas le savoir eh
oui c'est des problèmes qui sûrement se
se réglaient faut pas être que goûter un
peu seul un système c'est un système qui
doit s'équilibrer alors si c'est pas par
l'âge c'est un engouement tahri
cotisations en baissant les pensions ou
il faut faire est attentif c'est qu'il
faut donner confiance aux jeunes et
donner notamment mais aussi à l'ensemble
de la population dans un nouveau système
un peu révolutionnaire quand même donc
pour donner confiance ou des garanties
de la stabilité du système et
l'assurance que les retraites sont
payées donc il faut bien pouvoir dire au
moins dans cinq dix ans sait au moins
qu'il aimerait parce que si on est qu il
y pas avec des mesures d'âge on fait
quoi au moins et qu'il eut avec le point
problème la réforme pas point saint
système à rendement définit donc
l'équation entre le nombre de cotisants
qui n'arrête pas de diminuer le nombre
de pensionnés qui augmente avec une
durée plus longue
fait que si on touche pas c'était la
madame est en baisse la valeur du point
et on règle le dispositif
donc ce qui peut être la variable
d'ajustement en baissant le point vous
avez des retraites donc ça peut être une
garantie de faibles retraites c'est pas
la volonté du gouvernement me
semble-t-il
il veut garantir au moins un niveau de
vie moyen des retraités de demain il
faut quand même déjà consolidé me
semble-t-il le système qui soit bien
équilibrée quel que soit le mode de
calcul actuel où le futur mode de calcul
bien l'équilibré puis à ce moment par
des bases de confiance aux devoirs il y
aura des gagnants des perdants réussi
est limité et puis on examine tout ça
tranquillement on aimerait mais c'est
une affaire complexe 1 on aimerait bien
qu'ils aient pas de perdant une des
idées que j'ai entendu qu'ils
circulaient y aura nécessairement ceux
qui ont aujourd'hui un régime spécial
ne vont-ils pas y perdre rsa des projets
à voir ceci dit c'est vrai que dans un
certain nombre de régimes spéciaux
la réalité des choses c'est que les
cotisations du salarié couvre la moitié
de la dépense de ce qu'ils reçoivent et
c'est nous qui payons là oui non mélodie
fm enfin ils sont déséquilibrés sur plan
démographique de
pour garder tu vas c'est historique un
petit peu moi pourquoi moi pays à vous
parle a opposé une bonne question parce
que dans un mode de calcul différent et
pour que la réforme soit acceptable faut
qu'il y ait deux mois le perdant
possible ce qui veut dire que si on veut
le mois le perdant possible pour mettre
des sous sur la table parce que
automatiquement il y aura aussi on ne
nous dit plus de solidarité les pensions
plus base qui seront rehaussés etc
on prend pas leur apogée là pour donner
la pause les autres ça c est donc faudra
mettre de l'argent sur la table donc
faut mettre de l'argent sur la table
pour que les l'incarnant possible faut
mettre de l'argent sur la table c'est
estimer quand même par le corps pour l'
équilibre donc ça fait des sommes qui
commence à devenir importante donc il
faut quand même nous expliquait un petit
peu on va sur le plan de la trajectoire
financière quand même un équilibre qui
émeut le corps dit entre 7 et entre 9 et
pourquoi c'est si large pour prendre ça
veut dire qu'à un moment donné
voilà alors il faudra que ces sommes là
ça j'allais le dire tout à l'heure là je
me suis arrêté
c'est une une possibilité c'est de
comparer le système actuel avec ce que
donnera le nouveau système est de voir
effectivement là où il y en a qui
gagnent et là où il y en a qui perdent
et sociale de mettre une clause de non
perte si j'ose dire un mot pour conclure
justement ça serait peut-être quelque
chose qui pourrait permettre d'aller à
l'encontre lisation et des
manifestations un mot tout de même sur
cette manifestation du 5 décembre
on a beaucoup entendu le gouvernement
monte au créneau qui dénonçaient des
réflexes corporatistes là le premier
ministre d'un philippe tout à l'heure a
plutôt dit respecter un les grévistes et
la mobilisation
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
cette mobilisation qui se prépare et qui
se prépare d'ampleur écoutez dans une
démocratie c'est tout c'est normal on
peut ne pas être d'accord on peut dire
voilà ils défendent où ils pensent
qu'ils défendent leur pré carré leur
position mais c'est normal il faut pas
non plus que
ça met le pays en mauvais état voilà
rené paul savary vous votre avis sur
cette contestation nous sommes à une
semaine du 5 décembre
c'est à dire que moi je pense qu'il faut
rassembler les gens et pas les divisent
et quand on dit qu'il y en a qu'on ait
un avantage par rapport à nous et on les
divise quand on dit que la réforme elle
sera plus juste mais quand la reporte à
eau aux générations futures ça veut dire
qu'on maintient les inégalités donc dans
la proche du gouvernement faut peut-être
qu'ils améliorent leur communication
visiblement c'est pas compris porte
alors d'accord pour aviser les bains
voilà quand vous êtes dans la rue vous
discuté avec des gens dont j'en ai
encore pas trouvé à qui sautait sur sa
chaise on applaudit quand seulement dire
que je souhaite bien quoi tout le monde
dit oui il y aura sûrement besoin
d'améliorer les choses d'équité
d'équilibré le système de retraite de
garantir cela nos enfants mais les
efforts on sait bien qu'ils vont être à
partager donc derrière faut
impérativement être attentif à tout ça
est plutôt rassembler les gens que les
diviser parce que j'ai le sentiment moi
comme d'autres que le mmm est dur et
long elles ont alors plus on tergiverse
- koné les choses vous savez l'anxiété
et source un peu de fantasmes parfois
donc il vaut mieux dire la vérité aux
gens même si c'est demain je ne sais pas
moi j'ai invente un demain on dit aux
gens il faut travailler plus longtemps
mais sont peut-être capable de
comprendre faut pas les prendre pour des
billes quand même bien disons la vérité
puis on avance
sinon moi je pense que
le la proposition qui est sur la table
est effectivement sans doute ya un petit
manque de pédagogie
parce que telle que je la comprends elle
a une valeur universelle
elle est la même pour exactement tout le
monde tous les travailleurs quels qu'ils
soient pas simplement les salariés pas
seulement le public le privé mais aussi
les professions libérales et tout ça
sera exactement le même système c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est plus
juste et plus équitable gens devraient
ça devrait unifier le pays bas
savary va pas vous dire un non sa
retraite parfois tout à fait et puis le
système par points est sûrement plus
égalitaire sauf que c'est la transition
qui fait parce que il ya une histoire un
pays où ces mecs faut être sensible
il ya parfois vaut mieux avancer par
petites touches pour arriver à ses fins
que de faire une grosse révolution où
finalement on arrive à ce que soit on va
aller mal constitué
soyons prudents bien merci beaucoup
monsieur d'avoir participé à ce face à
face sur la question des retraites un
sujet dont on va avoir l'occasion de
reparler bien sûr autre mobilisation
celle des agriculteurs
plus d'un millier de tracteurs ont
convergé vers paris aujourd'hui certains
sont même arrivés sur les champs-elysées
l'objectif des manifestants interpellés
l'exécutif et la grande distribution
alors que commencent les négociations
commerciales qui fixe les prix pour un
an tout de suite et bien nous allons
rejoindre quentin calmet salle des
conférences à votre micro michel raison
michel réseau qui a travaillé à faire un
bilan de la loi agriculture alimentation
c'est un texte qui devait permettre aux
agriculteurs de sortir de la crise
d'évidence à n'a pas tout à fait marcher
oui tout à fait puisqu'il manifeste
effectivement aujourd'hui tam alors
michel raison bonjour vous étiez
rapporteur de cette loi et gally mais
aussi donc en charge ce suivi de la loi
et galim qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné avec cette loi qui était
censé comme cela rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs entre les forces entre eux
entre les agriculteurs et la grande
distribution
or déjà la première remarque c'est que
de toute façon ne pouvait pas régler le
dossier du revenu agricole uniquement au
travers de 1/5 des produits vendus par
l'agriculture ça c'est la première
remarque donc il ya eu une sorte de de
mensonges aux agriculteurs en leur
disant on va traiter le problème de
votre brigade il ne concernait que
vraiment une parente
via la sélection elle puisque tout ce
qui est exporté tout ce qui est vendu en
hors domicile les céréales d'abord tous
les produits sont pas vendus à la grande
distribution donc on a fait le calcul
précis on est un cinquième des produits
vendus sachant qu'ils recettes des
agriculteurs ne sont pas que les
produits vendus il ya la pac et c'est
les produits vendus x un tonnage ou un
litrage est ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui la loi galim c'est un flop
oui on peut le dire mais nous on avait
quand même dit sans faire de jeu surtout
pas faire de politique politicienne sur
ce dossier que trop grave et dans nos
intervention liminaire
on avait dit qu'on ne voyait pas comment
on pouvait régler le problème du revenu
des agriculteurs
alors si on en vient
au thème précis de la loi et galets
maintenant sur ce qui aurait fonctionné
au dysfonctionné c'est à dire entre les
relations entre les fournisseurs qui
sont des intermédiaires des agriculteurs
et les distributeurs
moi j'ai été 10 ans débuté j'étais à
l'assemblée à des deux spécialistes sur
le sujet des relations fournisseurs
distributeurs
moi je proposais ne change plus la loi
parce que chaque fois qu'on change la
loi les distributeurs grande
distribution trouve une solution pour
les contourner et de toute façon il ya
toujours des effets pervers
mais alors comment est ce que on peut
comme cela améliorer l cette question du
revenu des agriculteurs est ce qu'il
faut pas que le consommateur paye
davantage c'est dans l'arrêt de toute
façon ce qui est sûr c'est que le
consommateur ne paye pas son juste prix
produit mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a pas réglé le problème
on a quatre cinq grands distributeurs
qui se font la guerre des prix le
politique n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
sur le prix ni sur le marché on a
d'autres pouvoirs en matière de charges
en matière de mai sur ce dossier là on
n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir
donc il faut au moins qu'on essaie que
les lois qu'on vote ne fasse pas l'effet
inverse de ce qu on imaginer au moment
où vivote
un dernier mot sur cette agri becht ling
dénoncé par ses manifestons aujourd'hui
à l'appel de la fnsea et des jeunes
agriculteurs
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait constituer
français avec les agriculteurs
alors je veux pas dire qu'ils sont en
brouille d'ailleurs est que les français
parce que les français entre le son une
partie d'entre eux le sont et
c'est un problème de communication mais
c'est votre métier et vous savez que
c'est très difficile vous savez aussi
que la communication négative est
toujours facile à faire passer et que la
négociation la communication positive
est difficile et moi je je souhaiterais
qu'il ya un accord entre tous les
organismes agricoles et l'administration
aussi aux valeurs le ministre ceux qui
s'occupent de notre pays une
communication réelle sur la réalité de
ce qu'est l'agriculture sur des réalités
scientifiques et ce que vivent
réellement les agriculteurs merci
beaucoup mais c'est une raison on a
entendu a effectivement tout édification
du cours public sénat merci merci
beaucoup
quentin alors que nous sommes dans une
dizaine de minutes maintenant du début
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement on voit d'ailleurs
et bien que cela se remplit dans la
salle des conférences du sénat avant
cette horde échanges directs entre les
sénateurs et l'exécutif et j'ai plaisir
d'accueillir en plateau emilie zapolsky
bonjour je vous êtes communicante et
fondatrice de l'agencé my conseils
nous allons parler ensemble est bien de
ce que l'on peut attendre comme temps
fort a pour cette séance
il va d'ailleurs avoir des questions et
bien sûr l'agriculture sur la
mobilisation aujourd'hui des
agriculteurs cela s'explique aussi parce
que eh bien les agriculteurs ils ont été
assez déçu par l'exécutif qui pourtant
avait fait une grande loi sur le sujet
alors oui vous parlez de la loi et galim
le flop dont parlait michel raison juste
à l'instant
alors oui c'était une loi qui était
censé rééquilibrer les prix de la grande
distribution pour que les agriculteurs y
trouvent leur compte
finalement on voit que le bilan est en
demi teinte il ya un peu de résultats
mise à part je crois sur la filière du
lait donc il ya de la déception mais ça
s'explique quand même pas que là dessus
que les agriculteurs prennent la parole
dont ils vont aux champs elysées ça nous
rappelle quand même des événements qui
ont eu lieu l'année dernière en novembre
2018 les gilets jaunes avaient choisi
aussi donc il ya cette idée de révolte
qui est possible en quelque sorte qui a
été un petit peu lancé par les gilet
jaune
pourquoi pas eux pourquoi n'y at-il pas
manifestés eu également à paris pour
faire valoir leurs droits pour demander
pour faire mention de leurs
revendications il ya un peu cet élan qui
a été donné et puis il ya tout ce qui se
passe aussi sur
les incendies des exploitations récent
une espèce d'agri bashing qui se passe
en ce moment avec les vegan les
antispécistes il ya toute cette
atmosphère et récemment le ministre de
l'agriculture les a défendues en quelque
sorte sur ce village est aujourd'hui
didier guillaume à qu'il soutenait cette
manifestation et qu'il comprenait les
raisons de la colère des agriculteurs
faut dire aussi que lui n'était pas aux
manettes au moment où il ya eu la loi et
galim ce n'était encore que stéphane
travert c'est peut-être plus facile pour
le ministre actuel de l'agriculture donc
de défendre les agriculteurs mais où ils
ont du coup et une fenêtre de tir en
quelque sorte ont leurs revendications
dans la rue aussi pour ce soutien
affiché donc du gouvernement et en même
temps avec des difficultés puisque on
voit bien que la société une partie de
la société se dirige vers un mode de
production ou aimeraient en tout cas un
mode de production et un modèle
d'alimentation complètement différent
donc il va y avoir une sorte de rupture
qui dépasse même le cadre de la
politique du gouvernement sur des
attentes très fortes d'une société qui
veut autre chose qui veut de la qualité
qui veut des produits avec des animaux
qui sont bien très bien
il ya quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
plutôt de sociologie quoi de la société
et qui va dépasser le cadre des
politiques et des relations avec la
grande distribution est un signal aussi
c'est que la grande distribution des
chiffres ils sont pas très bons or ils
sont bons pour les petits hypermarchés
qui sont en ville les espèces de deux
marchés clés ghana touchant leclerc etc
mais sinon la grande distribution va mal
donc on voit bien que la société est en
train de bouger là dessus
comment la filière agricole peut s'y
retrouver là-dedans on voit qu'ils
vivent quand même avec peu de revenus
que les modèles économiques sont très
compliqués à exploiter donc il va y
avoir il va y avoir vraiment une filière
en danger d'ici peu une personne n'aime
plus les agriculteurs pourront vous
aujourd'hui en tout cas il n'est même
plus un certain modèle d'agriculture
alors un certain modèle s'assied sur
d'agriculture mais parmi les
agriculteurs qui viennent aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il y en a qui ont déjà fait un
modèle opté pour un modèle différent
c'est simplement les modes de
distribution est ce qu'on est est ce
qu'on arrive à développer les circuits
courts des modèles ou les où les
consommateurs sont plus proches des
producteurs pour que la grande
distribution prennent moins sa
commission il ya tout ce système à
penser et j'ai l'impression qu'on en est
qu'au début
débuts sur ces circuits courts et cette
agriculture un petit peu plus de qualité
et de proximité auprès des consommateurs
autre sujet de mobilisation n'en a parlé
plus tôt dans cette émission et bien
c'est la grève bien sûr du 5 décembre on
est à huit jours de cette journée de
mobilisation de manifestations déjà un
mot sur la méthode qui a eu le
gouvernement sur cette réforme des
retraites on a beaucoup parlé de
cafouillages de cacophonie de flou bon
aujourd'hui il ya eu la parole du
premier ministre edouard philippe
on commence à avoir un petit peu de
lumière au bout du flou du tunnel moi je
dirais que c'est un petit peu la méthode
du gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on a un
petit peu de la visibilité sur le
calendrier puisqu'il a donné précisément
quand est ce que monsieur de le voir
aller parler parce que les mains
monsieur défense ou 10 décembre début
enfin au début des années 2020
on aurait le texte on voit qu'on fait un
petit peu dur et quand même et qui a
quand même derrière des municipales 2020
qui s'annonce donc le gouvernement a
tout intérêt à été à l'esa dans la durée
mais il ya aussi cette volonté de pas en
dire trop
et moi je dirais que ce qu est ce qu a
dit edouard philippe c'est pas si clair
que ça oui il enterre la clause grand
père mais il dit les retraités actuels
ne seront pas ne seront pas concernés
vendres a produit quelque part la
tradition alors entre la clause grand
père c'est à dire qu'il ya que les
jeunes qui rentreraient dans le dans le
marché du travail qui serait concerné et
d'autres c'est quand même pas très clair
on a l'impression que là et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que joue le gouvernement depuis
un moment déjà
ils attendent le curseur et le curseur
le signal ça sera la mobilisation du 5
décembre et ça sera est ce que l'opinion
publique soit suit ou pas ce mouvement
de grève et à partir de là on a
l'impression qu'ils auront le courage
d'aller plus dans le sens le fond de la
réforme parce que jusqu'à maintenant et
depuis juillet depuis le rappeur
delevoye ce qui manque c'est vraiment le
sens c'est le fond c'est les mesures est
ce que c'est une réforme budgétaire et
là pour le coup on comprendrait que il
faut repousser l'âge de leur déficit de
2025 a été un week-end dans la douleur
le corps l'a signalé on a un déficit est
ce que c'est pour créer ce régime
universel dont parle edouard philippe et
qu'il a mentionné là en disant on y
croit on veut plus de régimes spéciaux
mais un régime universel
est ce que c'est pour de la solidarité
pour les mères de famille
pour qu'elle ait une meilleure retraite
ou les petites retraites on a encore
encore beaucoup beaucoup d'incertitudes
sur cette réforme
eh bien merci beaucoup et me la passe
qui pour cet éclairage du manioc en être
question des retraites lors de cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
et d'ailleurs quand un vous êtes avec et
la porte-parole du gouvernement si bête
ndiaye justement pour revenir pour
parler de ce sujet si sensible
oui tout à fait à mes d'abord s'il
atteignait bonjour un mot sur ces treize
militaires de l'opération barkan qui
sont morts lundi soir le présent à
public en a parlé on s'en doute au
conseil des ministres
qu'est ce qu'il a pu dire aujourd'hui
est bien le conseil le conseil des
ministres a débuté par une intervention
du président de la république qui a tenu
à rendre hommage à nos soldats morts au
combat
il a rappelé qu'elle était l'importance
de l'opération militaire barkan qui se
déroule actuellement dans la bande
sahélo sahélienne double importance
d'abord parce que il s'agit d'aider à
stabiliser une région celle des trois
frontières qui aujourd'hui est en butte
à l'action de djihadistes évidemment
mais aussi importance pour la protection
de nos concitoyens ici en france nous
confirmer un hommage lundi après midi
aux invalides avec une cérémonie
particulière alors je peux effectivement
vous confirmer cet hommage qui sera
rendu par le président la république et
le gouvernement
à partir donc lundi probablement dans la
matinée l'elysée aura vocation à donner
des informations complémentaires sur le
déroulé de ce moment qui je crois sera à
la fois un moment d'émotion mais
également un moment très solennel dans
lequel seront évidemment impliquer les
familles des militaires qui ont disparu
sim et n'diaye deuxième sujet que nous
allons évoquer ensemble ce dossier des
retraites une semaine neuf jours de la
grande mobilisation du 5 décembre à
cette tentative de l'exécutif de
clarifier là où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui
alors comment ça va se passer qu'est ce
que dit le premier ministre exactement
le premier ministre a donné un certain
nombre d'indications à la fois de
calendrier à l'issue de ces rencontres
bilatérales qu'il a eu avec les
organisations syndicales donc il a
indiqué que la fin des concertations
interviendrait vers le 9 ou le 10
décembre jean paul delevoye aura
l'occasion
après une utile at herald indiquer ce
qu'il retient de ces rencontres diverses
et variées y aura eu je crois à l'issue
de cette période près de 350 réunions
avec les organisations syndicales
patronales et professionnelles
je suis le premier ministre par dans
l'ue eux-mêmes aura l'occasion d'ici la
fin de l'année de s'exprimer pour donner
dans le détail ce que seront les
arbitrages du gouvernement pour cette
réforme
edouard philippe a dit on doit trouver
le bon curseur sur la date d'application
de cette réforme ça veut dire qu'il y
aura ce secteur par secteur branche par
branche des négociations pour l'entrée
en vigueur de la réforme des retraites
alors l'objectif n'est pas d'avoir des
choses qui sont décalées dans tous les
sens il est bien de pouvoir dire à la
fois que aux français qui sont proches
de la retraite il faut déterminer à
combien de temps de la retraite on leur
permet en quelque sorte d'avoir le temps
de s'organiser parce que vous pouvez
avoir fait des choix de carrière qui
influe sur votre retraite parce que vous
connaissez les modalités actuelles de
calcul un dernier mot sur cette phrase
qui fait beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis ce matin vous avez dit
que la réforme des retraites était une
réponse avec